olinia Air Base it's near Finland and
it's the headquarters of Russia's Naval
reconnaissance air division now it
normally houses heavy bombers and cruise
missiles it's an important staging
ground for Russian military operations
in Ukraine on August 21st an Israeli
intelligence firm isi noticed something
unusual at olinia Air Base satellite
imagery detected the quote unusual
presence of four tu-160 Russian
strategic bombers there on site now
these are strategic supersonic bombers
that are designed to carry nuclear
weapons you're seeing the satellite
images from olinia Air Base on your
screen right now
then just days ago on September 25th
Israeli intelligence spotted three more
Russian strategic bombers at olenya
these were tu-95 turbo props they're one
of the oldest nuclear-capable missile
Platforms in Russia's Arsenal so prior
to August the Jerusalem Post reports
there were no strategic bombers at
olinia now as of this week there are at
least seven Ukraine is now well within
the range of both bombers
in related news the deputy of head of
Ukraine's intelligence just determined
that there's a quote very high risk of
imminent tactical Nuclear strikes on
Ukraine now given all of this every NATO
Country Now needs to answer a very basic
question how are you going to lower the
temperature how are you going to prevent
Global nuclear war it's really the only
question that matters
our leaders though have no answer none
whatsoever instead of calming tensions
in fact they seem to be deliberately
provoking Russia Today Joe Biden once
again accused Vladimir Putin of blowing
up his own pipeline She also asked me
earlier about the pipeline and let me
say this it was a deliberate Act of
sabotage
and now the Russians are pumping out
disinformation lines and at the
appropriate moment when things calm down
we're going to be sending divers down to
find out exactly what happened we don't
know that yet exactly but if we're not
just don't listen to what Putin was
saying and what he's saying we know is
not true okay don't listen to Putin
should we then listen to Joe Biden in
February Biden said this quote if Russia
invades then there will no longer be a
nordstream too we will bring it to an
end and in the state department Victoria
Newland she said the same thing she said
quote if Russia invades Ukraine one way
or another
nordstream 2 will not move forward now
what's interesting is those threats
reveal who has incentive for nordstream
2 to come to an end you see the reason
our leaders would make those threats is
because Nordstrom 2 helps Putin there's
no reason for him to sacrifice his
leverage over Europe by destroying his
own Pipeline on the other hand we all
know who is capable of shutting down his
own pipeline that would be Joe Biden and
the Keystone XL pipeline now look there
are those in all fairness who say the
following they say this is Russia's way
bombing their own pipeline of
constricting supplies so that they can
jack up Global oil and gas prices and
then in turn make more money on existing
contracts with India and China
but here's a question why blow up your
own infrastructure why not you know just
turn off the tap in fact that's exactly
what Vladimir Putin did just a few weeks
ago he's shut down the nordstream 2
pipeline there was no gas flowing
through a pipeline that now he's being
accused of bombing and sabotaging in
order to constrict the supply of oil and
gas a supply of which none was flowing
through nordstream 2. now to be clear I
don't know who is responsible for this
I'm just trying to logically follow
incentive and if the U.S or its allies
sabotaged Russian pipelines it wouldn't
be the first time in 1982 Ronald Reagan
authorized the CIA to blow up a Siberian
natural gas pipeline using software
so we American citizens before we march
to a drum beat directly into Global
nuclear war are entitled to answers you
know who else is entitled to answers
climate activists you'd think they'd
take notice you'd think they'd ask
questions why because the nordstream 2
leak caused more than 300 000 metric
tons of methane to enter the atmosphere
sounds like a lot right here's how much
according to Bloomberg that's roughly
quote the same climate impact over a
20-year period as the annual emissions
from about
5.48 million U.S cars
but our leaders even our green energies
are they're hoping we ignore all of this
and if that's the plan it just might
work because there's so much going on
it's hard to keep track in what I'm
about to do a crazy day that literally
flew under the radar flew under the
weather radar and the News cycle Russia
attempted to Annex parts of Ukraine and
then in turn the U.S announced new
sanctions on Russia
we're announcing new sanctions today as
well
that including new authorities to
sanction anyone who provides political
or economic support to Russia's
fraudulent territorial claims and I've
been in close touch with our NATO allies
who are united in our resolved to take
on his aggression once more or less
there to ask a few critical questions
let's dare to critically think
why would more sanctions deter Russia
the last seven months of sanctions have
led to blackouts and food shortages in
Europe meanwhile in Russia the ruble got
stronger oh by the way our economy
Tanked
history has shown in fact that from
Japan to Syria to Russia sanctions don't
deter they provoke
and maybe that's the goal it's the only
way to achieve regime change in Russia
which is the stated goal of the Biden
Administration remember Putin quote
cannot remain in power Joe Biden's words
last March and he means it in April
Russia and Ukraine had a tentative
agreement to end this war Ukraine could
have kept its territory all they had to
do was promise not to become a NATO
member because NATO wants to remove
Putin from power but the Biden
Administration and the UK vetoed that
deal
so again a critical question is this
really about keeping Ukraine safe or is
it about regime change in Russia even if
that means starting a World War
today if there was any doubt left the
president of Ukraine settled that
question he signed Ukraine's quote
expedited application to formally join
NATO
it's yet another slick well-produced
video from Kiev watch
yeah
foreign
nice pan on the handheld camera
if Ukraine joins NATO that means World
War under Article 5 of the NATO Charter
Millions die instead of trying to avoid
that catastrophe our media though is
telling us that is essentially
inevitable the New Yorker for example
just published this assessment quote
Fiona Hill an expert on Russia says that
we are already fighting in the third
world war whether we want to acknowledge
it or not
perhaps save for the whole nuclear
Holocaust over to NBC quote historian
Michael beschlas just compared Putin's
Russia to Nazi Germany before the start
of the second world war why because
Putin just announced that he's annexing
territories into Russia Ukrainian
territories into Russia is that
comparison Fair Putin to Hitler
NATO thinks so the foreign minister
Poland just pledged that NATO countries
will use nuclear weapons against Russia
if Russia's strategic bombers carry out
a first strike he said it doesn't even
matter if Ukraine is in NATO or not
and in Washington you will not find a
politician in either party who disagrees
on that point they all believe that
defending Ukraine is worth risking
Armageddon of course so does Lindsey
Graham he just also compared Putin to
Hitler
I hope we will also send a very clear
signal here that we're going to have
more Aid in the uh if we do an Omnibus
in December which I hope we will to fund
the government that will have a robust
package of Military Support taking
Ukraine into 2023 have we learned
nothing from the last century what
should we have learned that when it
comes to bullies and crazy people who
want to
you know put the world under the thumb
like Hitler we should believe what they
say we should stand up to them sooner
rather than later that was Republican
senator from South Carolina Lindsey
Graham standing right next to him
Democratic center from Connecticut
Richard Blumenthal why is virtually
every politician both parties trying to
provoke Russia into using those bombers
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight